hello welcome to this video playing
Peregrine 64 let's play something else
what can I do maybe maybe let's play the
classical Sicilian this is something
that I have never played in tournaments
as candy to the rouser f1 hmm FY is
uncommon but I don't know what black is
doing here e 6 g six probably a couple
of the most possible oh yeah he's
probably angling for some e 5 and I'm
going to just delay delay cancelling for
a bit hmm is he going 45 even now
sometimes it's possible to play hmm to
play without cancelling like with age 5
and so on that's probably not one of
those positions
ok
yeah I feel threatened the pilot bishop
on d3 so maybe I can take it off the
board yeah the open sea file but like
before maybe before 93 but i don't i
don't know it's probably still ok to
take um yes there f5 or e five yeah
sometimes f5 can also be um tricky ok
maybe i'll take and go queen to d7 f5
bishop f6 should be ok I hope
and now I can maybe play a five myself
interesting idea let's try maybe six
pawn is very weak but while looking very
weak but the long diagonal here can
prove can prove tricky to handle and
maybe just wants to go night g3 and kick
my Ruca way there hmm it's definitely
true now I should have thought about
that I mean beforehand
hm
they're couple of options can also try
no g5 and after age 60 think he just has
to go back so it doesn't help
yeah so back yeah energy five so i have
to prevent that
hmm Joe what now this one okay that I
didn't really expect well I don't like
to take that with the bishop but yeah
maybe I have to I'm sorry come antiques
i have e five this is an interesting
move getting rid of that weakish looking
pawn and using the somewhat awkward
situation that he has you on the back
rank it also sometimes supports 94 now
it doesn't look too bad
nope
it's easy to handle this
this okay what's the point Bishop age 6
yeah take first thing later so I can
untick with this is made on f1 so let's
stick with the Queen okay um probably
just back home like this cover the pawn
and go from them
here drew can see seven on 94 this is
what irritates me so I was covering this
first 92 nite h6 there's screen age six
check
white resigns hmm yeah not an expert on
this opening interesting set up there
with F 493 I've seen that in games but
no particular idea how this is best
answered I mean here black has a couple
of options I certainly have g 6 45 okay
i went to a traveling and a type of
setup it's definitely playable okay or
look very normal okay I took this and 20
27 yeah now I was thinking at five is
this what you what you should try that
looks like the most um consistent
follow-up to the earlier play and hear
my idea was Bishop f6 maybe King h8 with
Bishop f6 Kozma mingle Bishop g5 then
okay run slightly awkward slightly
awkward I mean this is given by the
computer with equal play okay now i went
there five which is certainly debatable
i really not sure about this decision
but at least it makes sure that f4 f5 is
not coming from white and this way also
his bishops looking somewhat awkward
yeah it's pretty normal i think so this
is bad because I rock t5 a move that I
didn't think of it all now I simply
assembly didn't didn't see that this is
a square I mean
someone would point point to me okay
that you know that you can actually go
to d5 I will probably do that but I
didn't recognize this possibility it's
pretty strong okay I went back he went
back again age six and Tia was
reasonably happy yeah I'm not sure now
the engine wants to go 95 but I don't
think this is bad and I was also pretty
cash for black yeah white simply doesn't
have a good movie him that that that
tension on the air foul yeah Tim I'm a
pawn up with a good position jan you
know yeah it was a reasonable game i
think didn't didn't see any big big
mistakes that I that are committed ok
thanks for watching